hello Sandra Aquafina I'm such big fans
of you both thank you so much for quiz
lady this movie was phenomenal I watched
it at Tiff to a crowded house and
everybody was just laughing so hard uh
we loved it so much and I'm from Toronto
so it brought me such Pride Sandra to
see a Canadian just like own it in that
theater um but yeah I I love you both so
much I have the most important question
to ask and I think this is going to be a
really fun one um is there a comfort
game show you love watching or have been
dying to ever be on for both of you I
just wanted to start singing the theme
song to
definition it is I'm dating myself here
um let's say I'm not necessar I feel
like I have too much anxiety about my
about game shows because my sister is
amazing at trivia and amazing game shows
and I remember absolutely when I was
younger just trying to get her on
actually trying to get her onto
definition cuz
she was so good at it um I think she
took that mantle up in in in my family
regarding like the comfort of of game
shows I love Jeopardy but it was always
a little little uh you need a lot of
knowledge for that I I always I like the
stakes of like kind of remember that she
was like a little bit
angry and she had like short red hair
and she'd like stand in the middle and
like kind of roast everybody do you
remember that show I I oh yes uh the
weakest link the weakest link yes I
would have led like that it's like
there's so much dopamine and anxiety
going on that I just be like you know
what I I gotta tell you when I when we
were growing up we would watch the
Family Feud oh yeah family that was like
we would watch it together as a family
yeah my parents and I we used to watch
Match Game and then I ended up actually
being on the Canadian version but I lost
and so but it was a fun experience it
just go so quickly which is so crazy
when you actually are in the middle of
an actual
game like it's not it's not like how it
is on TV um but that's a story for
another day um something that I really
loved about this movie was the chemistry
between you two uh it's so authentic and
genuine um this is a question for both
of you so what is one thing you each
value about the other as a scene partner
that might also have given you the
chance to extend your character in ways
you probably couldn't without one
another great question that is a great
question yeah I think Sandra um
she was as a scene partner she's she's
such an incredible actress that she's in
it and I think that to bounce off of
somebody who is in it and who allows it
it allows you to be in it too um it's
felt extremely fluid it it felt it
wasn't like we were doing a scene
sometimes like like our conversations
outside of the scenes versus when we
went into it um she was a very very
trust trustworthy scene partner who
allows you to to um just sees you and
reacts off of you constantly she's an
incredible actress yeah well one uh Nora
is very
interesting you know I mean she's very
very interesting like I don't know what
she's going to do so you have to really
pay attention not everyone's like that
you know but she happens to do that and
and and you know that's just the way
that she is but she's interesting and
then also I'd say it's um oh well what
she's a great improviser I mean when
you're talking about comedy you know we
were very very attuned to each other uh
because that has to be in in that in
that realm for it to be alive and I will
really Echo what she said like we we
really worked on our relationship like
not in a heart we really spent time
together we uh embraced each other and
we really cultivated that relation which
continues on we have a we have a deep
relationship continuing on so so when we
were in scenes it was like um you you're
just in the pocket of your characters
and you're just reacting off of each
other yeah yeah and Aquafina I heard you
Sandra and director Jessica you you got
you guys collaborated on this like a
year before filming and you shared all
these different scenarios and including
what is the scene where Ann is you know
digging a hole so my question is was it
ever supposed to be that outlandish or
was there an alternate sort of scene cuz
I feel like that worked so perfectly
it's so tender but then it gets into the
story is so tender but then it gets into
something that's very like out of the
blue you don't expect you don't expect
it and I remember everybody in the
theater when we were watching it we were
like oh there's like it's very quiet but
then when then when the moment you say
what it is it's like oh and everyone
erupts in laughter and it's so funny and
the same thing with the dad's death I
thought was just so
yeah yeah I will say that um during that
summer we definitely like added things
into the script which was pretty much
there it was just it hadn't really been
written for uh Asian American uh Asian
women so we we me and Sandra with jens's
obviously like wanted us to do this we
wanted to fill in by telling stories so
I'm just gonna say that like it's not
there's not some of it's true they're
based on stories that we really shared
that really happened to us and I think
that like it's it's just when it's when
it's the truth or it's a true story that
maybe happened to you or someone in your
life and you you retell it it's like
it's just the truth I don't you know but
uh I won't tell you which ones
are yeah but it's I I would say it's
also common it's so common and it's so
Elemental so yes during that
time there were some of us in our that
group who you know shared stories of
that fundamental thing of like when
you're a kid and you're not in control
you know how an expression can happen
through you you know your Waterworks you
know what I mean and just saying in
the hole is funny yeah it's like you
know there's something Elemental that is
really funny and I think that is really
really relatable because I'll tell you
you know in in an audience of like I
don't know maybe there was like a
whatever let's say 800 people I bet
you 600 of them shot their pants when
they were a kid yeah it's true um you
know and Sandra you actually you really
play against type in this this is a role
we've never really seen you in um I'm
wondering what does it take to create a
balance of someone who has shared ands
trauma but also managed to really put it
aside for her little sister that she's
you know being the authoritative figure
to help her out oh yeah you know because
there's such an age difference between
the characters you can see the way that
each of the kids each of the sisters
dealt with uh their father leaving and
then dying and then also their mother's
gambling issue right so they just kind
of went opposite directions one was all
about chasing her dreams and kind of not
really being in reality and the other
one was like really being um uh kind of
going into
um what what am I doing like tuning
everything else like really kind of
tuning everything but making her world
really small because she just did not
feel safe um and so I think there's an
emotional thread and a character thread
that you can start building from there
because we're always building in some
ways in opposition from each other you
know I mean because you have you then
you create tension you create Dynamic
but mostly you create comedy um and then
of course you know they they they come
together in that emotional moment
because you know the film is about that
they have each other's back yeah yeah so
emo I I I mean all the steps in the
script from jendi Angel's script was
there of like how these how these two
sisters approach life from opposite ends
because of their shared trauma but then
come to this place where um they're just
really with each other and accept each
other a little bit more than they did
before for sure um before I let you go I
I do have to ask about that Cameo it was
so perfect and it just tied everything
together what was it like spending that
time with uh Paul Rubin in those final
scenes it was such a beautiful thing to
see and even I don't know if um you know
Jessica told you guys but at the Tiff
presentation they all came out the crew
came out wearing red bow ties to honor
him and everyone the crowd was just even
the woman beside me was just crying
because she thought it was so sweet but
um yeah please share your experience
with them I would love to hear it I mean
I was OB obsessed with with PeeWee
Herman like like so meeting him and and
I'm gonna I mean I don't know if this is
under WPS but but Sandra really helped
us because um one thing that never
changed in the script was that Cameo it
was always specifically him it was was
not changed and um I was I just remember
thinking like like my dreams would not
be able to come true that much that he
would say yes and Sandra made it happen
and he was you know he's H he was a huge
fan of Sandra um and he he came out and
and did it it was our first day shooting
right you just reminded me it was our
first day and he such a such a pleasure
yeah yeah it was your birthday it was
like your birthday it was Paul it was
the very first day it was meeting Paul
and it was like that you know if we
didn't get Paul this entire Francy
storyline wouldn't make
sense it's just one of those things
where it's like it you know you you you
hang on in this industry long enough and
you're going to know people so it was we
were like having a meeting and then I
was like okay I okay I I have Paul no
literally literally and I was like you
just you have what do you mean you just
have like like that's how much of a
baller Sandra is you know it just like
like wow yeah it happened almost
immediately yeah it did and then it was
like like he
was he's all the things that you uh
hoped he would be which is like so
joyous so lovely so odd and so um
genuine and and generous generous yeah
we were very very very lucky and we miss
him a lot I love that that I just got
chilled that so sweet to say but you
know um thank you so much for this movie
you have no idea I I have Asian Canadian
friends I'm a child of immigrants
understanding this trauma The Immigrant
trauma thing it's so real and so I
really appreciate it and I got to watch
with my sister and we just we just sawed
together it was such a beautiful movie
and it's so funny so thank you so much
to both of you I'm such a big fan
question